Since this is a vertical line, we know that its equation is going to be x equals
some constant, since every point along this line has the same x-value. Since
this line goes through the vertex, which has an x value of negative 5 halves,
the equation this line[INAUDIBLE] must be x equals negative 5 halves. Since this
line goes through the vertex, which has an x-value of negative 5 halves, the
equation in this line must be x equals negative 5 halves. I like to keep this
idea of the symmetry of parabolas in mind as we move forward. You probably
already noticed on your own anyway, just from looking at all of our graphs. But
think about why a parabola would end up with this kind of shape, because of the
way its equation is written. In particular, think about the fact that the
expression involving x is of degree 2, and how squaring something might create a
symmetric pattern just like this.